conozco su dolor sé que están heridos
Tuvimos una elección que fue robada fue
una elección ganada por gran distancia
todo el mundo lo sabe especialmente el
otro lado pero tienen que ir a casa
ahora tenemos que lograr la paz Tenemos
que tener ley orden tenemos que respetar
a las grandes personas que trabajan en
la ley y el orden no queremos que nadie
resulte herido es un momento difícil
nunca ha habido un momento como estos
donde una cosa así funcionara pasara
donde algo se nos quitara a todos a mí a
usted a todo el país esta fue una
elección fraudulenta pero no podemos
jugar como juega esta gente Tenemos que
tener paz Así que vayan a casa los
amamos ustedes son muy especiales ya han
visto lo que sucede ya han visto como
otros están siendo tratados de una
manera tan mala tan perversa sé cómo se
sienten pero vayan a casa vayan a casa
en paz